begin this morning with updates on the
controversial deaths of two black men
more than two thousand miles apart at
the hands of law enforcement officers in
Louisiana Baton Rouge Police released
body camera video of all Sterling's last
moments shedding new light on his death
in July 2016 and in Sacramento the
family of Stefan Clark released the
results of a private autopsy Friday
nearly two weeks after his death they
say that it showed the unarmed 22 year
old was shot eight times seven of the
bullets hitting him from behind that
prompted a fourth straight night of
protests in Sacramento and more planned
for today we start with John Blackstone
in Sacramento of the twitty bullets
police fired at Stefan Clark eight hit
his body according to an independent
autopsy performed for Clark's family by
pathologist Bennet Omalu
who says seven of the shots came from
behind each and every one of the wounds
independently possessed a fatal capacity
Alma Lu says his conclusion is supported
by video from a law enforcement
helicopter that captured the shooting
with a heat detecting camera first shot
he received would be number seven to the
left side and back of his chest and the
proportion of the bullet and the
injuries caused made him shot him around
and he was facing the officers the same
video viewed by others can seem to
suggest that Clark was moving toward the
officers the day after the shooting the
Police Department said in a statement
the suspect turned and advanced toward
the officers while holding an object
which was extended in front of him the
officers believed the suspect was
pointing a firearm at them
in a city where tension over the killing
has been rising for almost two weeks now
the independent autopsy is certain to
fool more anger and present yet another
challenge for Sacramento's first
african-american police chief Daniel Han
less than a year on the job this is a
huge test for you oh yeah there's no
doubt about that this is a huge test not
just for me but for our entire
department and for our community because
if all this is the stasis of tragedy and
we don't get better as a community as a
police department then it stays is
solely a tragedy and that in itself is a
tragedy the Sacramento Police Department
says it will not comment on the
independent autopsy until it receives
the official autopsy report from the
County Coroner for CBS this morning
Saturday John Blackstone in Sacramento